just like antibiotics I wouldn't want to
be told everyone's taking them so you
have to too yeah one size fits all Bill
Maher trying to save liberalism I dig it
I produced an entire separate series
talking about vaccines and sort of the
increase and I was a kid I I don't think
vaccines are a hoax or anything right I
just not a hoax but how you know do your
kids need from 1982 no they don't 6 to
75 you know I mean my view just to be
clear vaccines are a tool in the Medical
Kit just like antibiotics and just like
antibiotics I wouldn't want to be told
everyone's taking them so you have to
too yeah one SI fits all if I decide I
need one for a certain pathogen and I'm
at a place in my life where I think that
playing the odds which is what medicine
always is that would be the smart thing
okay but forcing it and on and in
children who never needed it for this
who the least likely and they're so sick
the kids have never been sicker and
that's start my series by asking these
kids have never been more vaxed we're
the most vaxed country in the entire
world you know we have these uh High
infant mortality rates one weighed
against third world countries and you're
being told that this is because we're
super healthy you got kids 75 vaccines
when I was a kid it was it was 12 you
know and there's been an explosion
people don't even know anything about
the diseases it's just these constant
fear campaigns and then on top of that
in States like La you can't opt out you
know so these are things that parents
have to think about now where you're
literally raising your kids could you go
to prison for saying that don't want my
child referred to as a different gender
behind my back yes depending on where
you live they're trying to criminalize
you being a parent um and then you add
that to the you know medical complex and
maybe you say you know I am I'm not
afraid if my kid gets chicken poox I got
chickenpox we chickenpox parties you
can't do that in La you can't do that in
LA and if you're a doctor and you say oh
this parent didn't want their child to
get the chickenpox vaccine you get your
license taken away in a place like La I
don't think parents realize why that's
so scary not necess we can argue all day
can call me antibac I can call you proax
but as parents we should be able to make
decisions for our children I don't fear
the chicken box that's all I was I mean
yes I would I would
really not go over well in today's world
if I was a parent I I would just be in
fights and it would just be
ugly